also yesterday a horrible horrible
incident in Berlin Germany uh we're at a
Christmas market 12 people were killed
in 52 injured or the latest numbers that
I have by a truck that was deliberately
driven into a crowd most of the victims
injured or killed were up were killed by
the truck rampage itself although there
was one victim actually shot dead and
found in the passenger seat of the truck
used for the rampage so the suggestion
of course is that the vehicle was
hijacked and that the man found in the
truck was the trucks original driver now
there's some controversy over the
alleged perpetrator here on a number of
fronts number one this is an demo that
has previously been associated with Isis
attacks you'll remember the incident in
Nice France where a truck was also used
in this exact manner that being said as
of right now and this may have changed
by the time you watch or listen to
today's program Isis has not been up
blamed nor has anyone claiming to
represent to be associated with Isis
taken responsibility so that's number
one but there's an additional element
here with regard to the alleged
perpetrator which is that we had initial
reports that a particular suspect was in
custody and that that suspect was a male
Pakistani refugee seeking asylum in the
in in Europe specifically in Germany and
of course when that happened the
conversation exploded about Angela
Merkel and the perception by some that
she is weak on undocumented immigration
on immigration more broadly that entire
narrative has now been called into
question again by the time people here
see this Pat some of these details may
have changed but the most recent
information from German officials is
that they believe that although they
have detained a Pakistani refugee seeker
that that individual may not have
anything to do with this attack and that
the actual perpetrator may be at large
in Berlin or other parts of Germany
which is very scary not to say the least
I think I'm glow Merkel is getting ahead
of this by saying that this is a act of
terrorism trying to you know make that
see reflect well on her especially asked
that she's
running for reelection as german
chancellor yeah i think this also just
goes to show that terrorism can be uh
perpetrated by guns by knives or can be
something like this bye-bye a weapon
that pretty much everyone is entrusted
with and the idea of X doesn't kill
people people kill people is something
I'm going to address a little bit later
because as a general idea I feel like
there's a double standard being applied
and pat your microphone is not muted
right I mean you're muted your urine
that's very good you're on fire I just
wanted to make sure sometimes I have my
uh my hearing is not a hundred percent
right I want to make sure pat comes
through clearly so everybody can hear
him uh okay so we I don't know that we
need to comment any further right now
about the suspect specifically because
in spite of the initial of claims that
this was a Pakistani refugees seeking
asylum in Germany that is not currently
known what we do know is that right wing
pseudo populism that has risen in Europe
is responding very loudly to this for
example we saw Marcus pretzell the
chairman of the right-wing populist
party alternative for Germany he
immediately tweeted when will the German
legal state strike back when will this
damned hypocrisy finally stopped these
are Merkel's dead and of course that
assumes a lot about the initial reports
with regard with regard to the alleged
perpetrator and sort of ignores the more
recent statements by police that they
may have the wrong person altogether
today's show is brought to you by
godaddy where you can buy your own
domain name build a website or use any
of Go Daddy's business tools you can
save thirty percent at try godaddy.com
slash david go daddy has actually been
the official host of the david pakman
show website for many many many years
the 24 7 customer support has been a
very good thing for us i've called them
at really odd times when we we've had
website issues and they are always
available they are the largest domain
registrar and whether you have a new
idea you're an established business
you're creating a personal website or
moving your large enterprise site over
to godaddy they can do it all 13 million
customers try it and get thirty percent
off at try godaddy.com / David